so far with obi-wan kenobi there are
some worrying issues and not the typical
dumb glaring moments like with leia's
chase scene but fundamental issues with
tone direction cinematography editing
and of course writing the thing i was
worried about the most that has
essentially come true which is the show
is not committing to a darker tone the
inquisitors hunting down the jedi in
post-order 66 is one of the darkest
parts of the star wars timeline and the
show makes it feel tensionless and like
it's not a big deal overall to me this
is mainly because the writers make the
inquisitors feel like middling villains
literally their opening scene where they
discover a jedi who ends up escaping
makes them seem like buffoons who are
bad at their jobs not to mention two of
them didn't even look like they were
trying to capture him and then just
throws down a raptor and they give up
chasing him i know the grand inquisitor
had to stop the third sister but this
act alone showcases so much incompetence
between them that they seem utterly
ineffective then when reva was
terrorizing some people and restoring a
bit of menace that was missing the other
inquisitor abruptly stops her so right
away the villains don't come across as
intimidating as they should be and
that's even exemplified through the fact
that there's a character posing as a
jedi for money and clearly isn't scared
of the consequences of being caught and
then he is caught and nothing really
happens to him i know reva didn't kill
him because he technically wasn't a jedi
but the whole idea of spreading hope and
jedi still being present in the world
should at least be punishable then
looking at the tone for the rest of the
show primarily regarding obi-wan the
writers don't really focus that much
time on him and they keep cunning around
to different happier areas like with
leia instead of fully immersing us in
obi-wan's tragic story like i assume a
lot of people were expecting a
logan-esque battered down character
study to start but what we get is a
shallow version of that where we have
brief moments that dredge up the past
most of his time is just chilling at
work and there's not a lot that invokes
or allows us to open up to obi-wan to
see how he truly feels instead of more
of a character study this first episode
felt way more plot-oriented which i
think is a bad overall direction choice
to make like you have eli mcgregor who's
a great actor so give him the material
and let him go to work and let the
audience be immersed again in his
character because what we have so far
with obi-wan is pretty interesting and
most of his scenes are actually good
it's just the show overall is one step
away from being great then there's
another glaring issue that's been
bugging me since the book of boba fett
which is how these shows are being shot
firstly it doesn't feel like they're
really trying to make the footage look
that cinematic i think a good example is
the introduction of the inquisitors
where they walk out of the ship and
everything is brightly lit there's no
contrast no interesting compositional
shots and instead they mostly rely on
wide shots this feels like a lazy
introduction and the cinematography is
not aiding the villains by making them
look menacing by any means if you
contrast this to the introduction of cad
bane where it's an extreme wide shot of
an unknown figure walking towards our
protagonist while obscured by the
radiating heat is so much more
mysterious and badass not to mention the
cool close-up showing off the great
design of the character but instead what
we get in obi-wan kenobi feels way more
generic and this isn't just for one
scene the cinematography throughout the
show so far never really blows you away
or wows you for what should otherwise
have a high production value this kind
of scares me for when they get to the
bigger action scenes because if it looks
anything like the action we've seen so
far then i'm definitely
scared but hopefully they are saving the
budget for the later episodes which i
assume are going to be more expensive
and one thing that especially does not
help the cinematography is the jarring
editing looking at the rooftop chase
scene alone i'm really surprised the
director looked at the scene and thought
it was okay between rapidly cut action
that makes everything feel incoherent
and choppy cutting between so many
different subjects reaching up to six
different people and the stupid force
parkour that is shown via wide shots
that makes her look like she's jumping
around on wires looks terrible all of
this combined with the lackluster
cinematography and weird plot beats like
lay jumping off a god damn rooftop makes
this all feel cheap not to mention i'm
picking scenes that are alright and not
the atrocious chase scene with leia or
should i say scenes which let's get into
leia because it feels kind of forced to
throw a witty quippy young leia who
looks like she's seven how old are you
ten
i don't sound like girl 10. acting like
she's 15 years old into a story that
should be focused on obi-wan the second
she showed up i immediately said oh god
don't just evolve the story into another
father-like figure escorting a kid road
trip adventure which has been done to
death along with him already doing that
with the mandalorian so hopefully she
doesn't become the primary focus for the
rest of the story and if she is then i
don't know what the writers were smoking
because they could have taken the story
in infinitely more interesting
directions than babysitting a
quote-unquote child who's written by an
adult who doesn't know how children act
this is confirming what i feared a few
months ago where an article came out
saying that disney rewrote the obi-wan
series because it was too dark and
knowing this all i can think is that
they interjected a young leia to
brighten up this story which surprise
surprise is what everyone dislikes the
most about the show so far so i feel
like the future quality of the show
hinges on a combination of disney maybe
trusting the original writers enough and
them brightening up the tone too much
because it's disney and that one hand
decapitation will probably be the most
violent thing you see i know this all
sounds very grim and i'm coming across
as hating the show but i feel very
passionate about obi-wan kenobi and i
want to critique what is wrong because
this story alone has so much potential
and i'm desperately hoping that disney
doesn't ruin it or even does a mediocre
job with it so far it's not worse than
the book of boba fett but we'll see how
it goes hopefully it gets a bit better